ja meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen bei wer weiß mehr dem großen
quiz bei clixoom
unser heutige kandidatin ist darum die
charmante darum und sie hat heute fragen
zu beantworten zum fachgebiet darum sie
haben sich jahrelang auf dieses quiz
vorbereitet
allerdings wird es nicht ganz leicht wir
haben auf jeden fall diesmal publikum
sogar der sonst nie haarwäsche so meine
damen und herren wir kommen zur ersten
schreiben bei eurer ersten geschwister
challenge
sie macht auch geschwister challenges
stand es am ende mit wie vielen punkten
für dich
keine ahnung doch ich weiß
ich muss erstmal die lösung so darf herr
gesangsverein
b 6 zu 4
7 zu 3 oder de 7 zu 4 also ich weiß ich
habe gewonnen
mein bruder wusste gar nichts über mich
möchtest du das einloggen
ich sag 7 zu
das lockt sie ja
leider fast 7 3 6 4
wir kommen jetzt zur zweiten frage
wie viele sinne man rolls sind bei
deinem back versuch herausgekommen
ac meyer
b12
c 15 oder d 17
beim einparkversuch ist auch schön
formuliert ist nämlich total in die hose
gegangen übrigens
nicht liebt
17 schon mal nicht 15 auch nicht sondern
12 ich glaube dass ein block sagt jetzt
sofort ihr wirklich sicher her so wenig
ich bin so ein symmetrischer mensch und
ich habe bestimmt drei und dann vier
gemacht ich denke mir grad mein
backblech werth straße noch mal intensiv
vor also du meinst zwölften zu helfen
ich bin richtig aufgeregt ist
einfach
nur loks 12 b 1 es war zäh 15 aber drei
und fünf aber der ansicht der brand wird
jeder genau deswegen habe ich ja noch
mal ich habe ja versucht ich habe das
wird ja auch habe ich ja weil hier
hinweise also wie viele videos befinden
sich in deine haare playlist
heißt dass jemand von euch
nee das kann man ja nicht verlangen das
ist jemand weiß natürlich muss jetzt mal
wieder die vorschläge
also 39
41 und jetzt ratet mal was de ist 72 und
es sind 39
39 1
das problem ist am ende denken die ich
betreibe main kanal gar nicht ja ich
logge 39 ok und sie werden denken wir
betreibt seinen kanal gar nicht das ist
falsch es sind 42
herzliches beileid henke
das wäre ihr preis gewesen kriege ich
den trotzdem sollen sie ihn trotzdem
bekommen
ok
mit geht es ja so bitte